every object-oriented language I can
think of has a way to dynamically refer
to the current object in JavaScript we
use the keyword this but as you and I
both know it can be pretty confusing at
times it doesn't always return the
object you're expecting it to I would
actually go so far as to say the
parameter this is easily the most widely
misunderstood aspect of the language but
it's actually pretty easy to use if
you're thinking about it in the right
way so you'll notice I'm always very
careful to refer to it as the parameter
this and that's because it behaves
almost exactly like a normal parameters
with a couple of exceptions parameters
are those words that we see between
parentheses in a function definition so
there's really just two major
differences between a regular parameter
and the parameter this the first is you
don't get to pick the name for the
parameter this it's always just going to
be referred to as this and the second is
you go about binding values to the
parameter this a bit differently from
how you bind values to other parameters
there's about five different ways in
fact that you can do that and we're
going to examine them all in an upcoming
lesson but before we do I'd like to just
take a quick detour and look at the dev
tools for a moment to examine a scenario
you might find yourself in where you
could start to ask the question what is
the parameter this is going to be bound
to in this case